CALLED THE ORDER PLEASE BE
ADVISED AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IT'S ALSO
BEING TELEVISED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM HERE CARILLO FLORA
GRAYSON HERE KAMLAGER
MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS YOUR FIRST
OVER HERE RAMOS HAS RIVAS WICKS
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM. OF A
QUORUM ELSE OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR- SECOND. MEMBER
MR MATHIS BY MISS WICKS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CUNNINGHAM HI
CUNNINGHAM I CARILLO FLORA
GRAYSON HI GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS FROM US I
RIVAS WORKS HI MIKE SIDE MOTION
CONCERT VERSION KERR IS WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OF THE FOR APPS
FOR FEW MINUTES.
DURING THE
REMOTE. THANK YOU. OVER TIME.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. SORRY WE
HAVE TO SHOW COMMITTEES ADJOURN.
THANK YOU.